hallo mein name ist sie willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video ich kenne das
ja bestimmt man hat langeweile ging wie
vorm schlafengehen nach dem schlafen
unter der dusche aufm klo beim es in
meinem trinken beim karten beim keine
ahnung was machen und dann steckt man
etwa so die ganzen sozialen netzwerken
wie facebook twitter skype chat
instagram von mailings bei instagram
meine damen und herren instagram da
kommste schlendern luca und irgendwann
landet man halt früher oder später auf
der seite nein geld und beim neugeld
werden halt immer so witzige bilder
beiträge videos gifft dat eines
vertrages und ich hab mir halten jedoch
jeder mensch war irgendwie schon mal auf
nein geht jeder kennt diese beiträge
warum mache ich einfach mal ein video
von den besten einweg beiträgen die ich
jetzt so beim bisschen durchscrollen
gesehen habe bein eingegipst locker
milliarden von beiträgen deswegen sorry
dass ich nicht alle irgendwie
durchscrollen konnte ich habe jetzt
einfach mal so durch kräuterwiesen 8
beiträge rausgenommen die ich besonders
cool witzig fand oder zu denen ich was
sagen könnte und die wollte ich einfach
nicht vorenthalten sondern einfach mal
zeigen also die kommen wirklich alle von
mein geld werde die auch da finde ich
wollte euch die nur zeigen und darauf
bisschen reagieren deswegen direkt an
die erste sache die ich da irgendwie so
gefunden habe ist eine aufnahme wo auf
der linken seite eine frau sich mit
sonnencreme eincremt und auf der rechten
seite die gleiche aufnahme allerdings
mit einer uv kamera also dass man genau
sieht wo jetzt quasi sonnencreme
beziehungsweise sunblocker aufgetragen
wurde
es ist einfach nur krieg
das sieht so crazy aus als ich das ist
richtig ekelhaft als ich das gesehen
habe dachte ich halt erst auf der linken
seite ganz normale menschen auf der
rechten seite so ein krasser zombie weil
es sieht schon krass creepy aus die
zweite sache die ich euch zeigen wollte
war diese zocker zimmer was dort
gepostet wurde dass ich ihnen allen
übels ist zucker zimmer zusammengebaute
drei bildschirmen oberen fernseher
anhängen der typ hat und noch zwei pcs
stehen so gaspedale und sowie irgend
welche rennspiele link stehen noch zwei
laptops und irgendwelche schaltknüppel
oben laufen längeren kopfhörer also
wirklich alter wenn ich das zimmer hätte
dass der ultra krass viele fragen sich
jetzt bestimmt die meisten zocker zimmer
hier zu hause gerade aussieht da kann
ich euch mal einfach kurzen bildern
blenden
der theoretische aber beinahe posten das
nächste bild was ich jetzt einfach ein
typischer luca online spielen und zwar
die der überschrift wenn man 0 kills
gemacht hat und 30 tore kassiert hat in
einem online spiel aber das team hat
immer noch gewonnen hat am ende das
sieht das sicher so aus und dass er mich
einfach nur an mich in online spielen
bei dem nächsten bild kann man sich
entscheiden und zwar muss man sich eine
von diesen vier möglichkeiten aussuchen
also möchte man einen komplett
funktionierenden ironmans judt an eine
pille die die lebensdauer verdoppelt
dann noch die möglichkeit dass man mit
irgendeiner berühmtheit den platz
tauschen kann und eine love potion die
bei jeder person funktioniert und da
müsste man sich jetzt entscheiden in der
überschrift wahl eingestanden dass die
leute die das halt da gepostet haben
gesagt habe dass sie den argument wählen
wollen ich denke allerdings dass ich
[Musik]
ich glaube ich würde auch den er in
landshut willen wenn ich das hier gerade
mal so durchgehe
also den platztausch mit ihm der
berühmtheit will ich auf keinen fall
weil das glaube ich mega anstrengend ist
ich will doch nicht doppelt so lange
leben weil das irgendwie so dann hätten
wir so ein alter gebrechlicher menschen
love potion bin ich total bescheuert
weil man kann ja nicht leute dazu
zwingen ihn zu lieben so das ist ja
irgendwie nicht so normal und all
weather das einzige was übrig bleibt und
ultra geil die nächste sache die ich
euch zeigen wollte war ein kleiner text
was mobbing scorpions geht heiße
grundproblem in pakistan unterhalten
außenposten make something like dancing
die scorpions kam die smog straight to
back lohesch also in pakistan rauchen
leute skorpion um high zu werden und das
hält bis zu zehn stunden an
what the [ __ ] in was für einer welt
leben wir dass ihr fucking skorpione
raucht jeder schritt vom nächsten post
war irgendwas in die richtung junge das
wird jetzt gerade entwickelt und das
kann die wende reinigen also ich weiß
nicht wo sie staub anwenden ablagert und
nicht auf geraden ebenen aber in ordnung
und dann wird halt ein video
eingeblendet wie das ganze ding
funktioniert
dann dachte ich mir so ok cool das kam
an die wand ploppen und das pferd an der
wand lang und reinigt die wand ist eine
sehr coole sache nur dann wurde gezeigt
wie das ganze ding bei nacht aussieht
das ist sehr kritisch stellt euch mal
vor ihr liegt im bett wacht auf und
wissen noch nicht dass eure eltern sich
dieses ding gekauft sondern auch einmal
so zwei grüne augen
die da so herfahren
jetzt hat einfach nur ultra creepy
kommission zum letzten beitrag gehe ich
heute zeigen wollte uns war es wieder
ein sex und zwar besagt dieser tech day
sale videogames welchem ireland beim
handelshof jesu wie burn people alive
lobbying witches und das ist etwas
worüber ich wirklich ganz ganz kurz
reden möchte ich habe es früher so oft
gehört von wegen lukas jocks tier cod
das ballerspiel passt mal auf mich dass
ein amokläufer wirst du irgendwann auch
menschen unbedingt leute es wurden auch
schon vor tausend jahren irgendwelche
menschen getötet und wusste nicht auf
irgendwelche spiele geschoben natürlich
sagt man bei irgendwelchen an bachläufen
oder gewalttätigen leuten oft ok auf der
festplatte boden legen nicht
ballerspiele gefunden aber diese leute
haben auch wasser getrunken
also ist jetzt jeder der wasser trinkt
gleichzeitig auch gefährdet irgendwie
leute umzubringen oder war der verfasser
von diesem neuen gag post hat am ende
auch ein tolles fazit gezogen und zwar
so proview mit tages gab es also
vielleicht sind die menschen halt
einfach ein müllhaufen
das finde ich jetzt ein gutes statement
um dieses video heute zu beenden wenn es
euch gefallen hat und ihr denkt judoka
das ist cool diese neue serie dass du
irgendwie so fünf bis zehn ein gag
sachen einfach nimmst dir gefallen und
irgendwie kommentiere school zeigt
blabla werden auf jeden fall den daumen
hoch waffen wie des todes also das zeigt
mir dadurch wenn jetzt haben wollt und
drückt einfach daumen runter wenn jetzt
nicht noch mal haben wollt ganz simple
entscheidungskriterien vielfalt von euch
da blabla und schreibt mir bitte
unbedingt in die kommentare was in eure
lieblingsmusik post also irgendwie den
titel oder was ich da suche soll das
dann das vielleicht das nächste mal
nächste woche übernächste woche
irgendwelches wieder macht seine ideen
und den nächsten